Estaba decidido a cambiar mi relación con el cáncer
y a aprender más sobre él
antes de decidirme sobre algo tan drástico como la cirugía.
Soy artista, uso varias tecnologías de código abierto
e información abierta en mi actividad.
Así que mi mejor opción era hacerlo todo público como información no confidencial
y hacerlo de modo que pudiera ser de libre acceso para cualquier persona.
Así que he creado un sitio web, que se llama "La Cura",
e hice accesibles mis datos médicos en línea.
En realidad, tuve que hackearlos
y eso es un detalle del que hablaré en otra ocasión.
(Risas)
Elegí esta palabra, "La Cura",
porque en italiano significa "remedio"
y porque en muchas culturas diferentes,
la palabra "cura" puede significar muchas cosas diferentes.
En nuestra cultura occidental
significa erradicar o hacer retroceder la enfermedad,
pero en otras culturas,
por ejemplo, las culturas asiáticas,
las del Mediterráneo, la de los países latinos, la africana,
puede significar muchas otras cosas.
Por supuesto que estaba interesado en las opiniones de los médicos,
del resto de los profesionales de la salud
pero también estaba interesado en la cura ofrecida por un artista, un poeta,
un diseñador,
o, por qué no, de los músicos.
Estaba interesado en la cura social,
la cura psicológica,
la espiritual,
la emocional,
estaba interesado en cualquier tipo de curación.
Y funcionó.
La página web de "La Cura" se convirtió en viral.
Recibí mucha atención mediática en Italia y en el extranjero,
más de 500 000 personas me contactaron en muy poco tiempo
a través del correo electrónico, las redes sociales;
en la mayoría de casos con algún consejo sobre cómo curar el cáncer,
pero muchos más trataban de sugerirme cómo curarme
como individuo.
Por ejemplo, miles de vídeos,
imágenes, fotografías, representaciones artísticas
se crearon para "La Cura".
Por ejemplo, aquí vemos a Francesca Fini y su actuación.
O lo que ha hecho el artista Patrick Lichty:
una escultura en 3D de mi tumor
a la venta en el Thingiverse.
Así que ahora ¡pueden tener mi cáncer, también!
(Risas)
Lo que es genial si lo piensan,
podemos tener el mismo cáncer para compartir.
Y esto es lo que pasaba:
científicos, expertos en medicina tradicional,
varios investigadores, médicos,
todos conectados conmigo para hacer recomendaciones.
Con base en toda esta información y consejos
reuní un equipo de varios neurocirujanos,
médicos tradicionales,
oncólogos y varios cientos de voluntarios
con quienes tuve la oportunidad de comprobar la información
que estaba recibiendo, lo cual es muy importante.
Y juntos, pudimos desarrollar una estrategia diseñada para mi cura
en muchos idiomas, según muchas culturas.
Y la estrategia actual abarca conocimientos de todo el mundo
y miles de años de historia humana,
lo que es bastante impresionante.
[Cirugía]
Las siguientes resonancias magnéticas confirmaron por fortuna
poco crecimiento o más bien la ausencia del cáncer.
Así que tuve tiempo para elegir.
Elegí el médico con quien quería trabajar,
dónde hospitalizarme
y todo mientras miles de personas me apoyaban
sin que nadie sintiera lástima por mí.
Todo el mundo sentía que podía tener un papel activo
para ayudarme a sentirme mejor
y esa fue la parte más importante de "La Cura".
¿Cuáles fueron los resultados?
Estoy bien, como se puede ver, muy bien.
(Aplausos)
Tengo una excelente noticia:
después de la cirugía...
tengo... tenía un glioma muy pequeño
que es un tipo de cáncer "bueno" y que no crece mucho.
He cambiado por completo mi vida y mi estilo de vida.
Todo lo que hice
fue cuidadosamente diseñado para que me mantuviera involucrado.
Todo hasta los últimos momentos antes de la cirugía,
que fue algo muy intenso,
me implantaron una serie de electrodos en el cerebro
por este lado,
para poder construir un mapa funcional de lo que controla el cerebro.
Y justo antes de la operación
pudimos discutir ese mapa funcional de mi cerebro
con el médico, para entender los riesgos que corría
y si había alguno que quería evitar.
Obviamente los había.
[Ser abierto]
Y esta apertura fue realmente la parte fundamental de "La Cura".
Miles de personas compartieron sus historias, sus experiencias.
Los médicos llegaron a consultar gente con la cual no suelen hablar
cuando se trata del cáncer.
Me he autoconstituido y me encuentro en un continuo estado de traducción
entre muchos idiomas diferentes,
donde la ciencia se encuentra con la emoción
y la investigación académica se encuentra con la investigación tradicional.
[Sociedad]
La parte más importante de "La Cura"
fue sentirse parte de una sociedad realmente comprometida y conectada
cuyo bienestar depende verdaderamente del bienestar de todos sus componentes.
Esta intervención global es mi cura de código abierto para el cáncer.
Y por lo que veo,
es una cura para mí, pero también para todos nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)